buonasera dunque le parole con cui
potrei cominciare a raccontare questa
storia sono c'era una volta in un
universo in una galassia lontana lontana
e quello che non funziona
ecco quello che vedete infatti dietro di
me nella rappresentazione di due buchi
neri che dopo una danza durata milioni
di anni si sono avvicinati sempre di più
orbitando uno intorno all'altro e alla
fine della loro vita si sono fusi per
formare un buco nero di massa ancora
maggiore questa fusione avvenuta
veramente ad una distanza grandissima
dalla terra più di un miliardo di anni
luce da noi e ha liberato un enorme
quantità di energia che ha viaggiato
nell'universo ha raggiunto la terra dove
ha prodotto un segnale piccolissimo che
noi abbiamo misurato questa misura è
stata considerata una scoperta
fondamentale della scienza e io voglio
raccontarvela partendo dalle persone che
l'hanno resa possibile è una storia
durata molti anni fatta di alti e di
bassi ma come spesso accade nella
scienza e nella vita
anche gli insuccessi hanno contribuito
per farci capire come andare avanti come
migliorare fino a raggiungere
l'obiettivo finale non è mai semplice
capire l'inizio di una scoperta dunque
partiamo da qualche anno fa e
precisamente un centinaio di anni fa
quando nel 1915 albert einstein ha
pubblicato alla teoria della relatività
generale
dopo molti anni di lavoro questa nuova
teoria non fu immediatamente accettata
dalla comunità scientifica servì del
tempo e delle verifiche sperimentali ma
quando ciò accade fu chiarissimo il
potenziale innovativo che portava con sé
la relatività generale fu considerata
una rivoluzione nella scienza una nuova
teoria dell'universo che superava
completamente la visione precedente e
per capire qual è il cuore della
relatività generale
immaginiamo di descrivere lo spazio come
una griglia un punto in questa griglia
rappresenta un punto nello spazio
einstein ci dice che se prendiamo una
massa e la poggiamo su questa griglia
la mossa deforma la struttura dello
spazio intorno a se cambiano le distanze
tra i punti viene prodotta una curvatura
lo spazio inizialmente piatto si curva
per effetto della presenza di materia e
grazie a questo concetto che noi
possiamo spiegare il moto dei pianeti la
terra orbita intorno al sole perché si
muove su quella che è la traiettoria più
naturale in uno spazio curvo così come
farebbe una piccola massa in un imbuto
che naturalmente si muoverebbe su una
traiettoria curva è proprio la massa a
rappresentare la gravità il campo
gravitazionale quindi la gravità che la
terra sente coincide con la curvatura
prodotta dal sole e non solo lo spazio
viene curvato viene deformato ma anche
il fluire del tempo a essa in ci dice
che il ticchettio di due orologi cambia
a seconda del campo gravitazionale in
cui essi si trovano più la gravità è
forte più il tempo scorre lentamente e
di quanto la struttura spazio temporale
renga deformata da questo dipende da
quanto la massa e densa se immaginate di
prendere il sole e di racchiuderlo in
volume sempre più piccolo quindi creando
un oggetto sempre più denso e compatto
ecco questo avvallamento nella
membrana dello spazio tempo aumenta
sempre di più in profondità affinché
immaginate di concentrare la massa in un
punto
ottenete una deformazione norme quasi un
pozzo senza fondo ottenere quello che
fisici chiamano un buco nero
la gravita intorno a un buco nero è così
forte che nessun oggetto se si avvicina
abbastanza neanche la luce riesce più a
sfuggire
e per questo che si chiama buco nero è
un oggetto che non emette luce che non
emette radiazione se anziché prendere
una singola massa afferma noi prendiamo
ad esempio due corpi che orbitano uno
intorno all'altro quindi si muovono sono
accelerati
ecco vedete questi provocano delle
increspature nella struttura dello
spazio tempo delle onde che partono
dalla sorgente che li genera e si
propagano dell'universo alla velocità
della luce sono le onde di gravità onde
gravitazionali che il concetto di honda
gravitazionale che fu einstein stesso ad
introdurre un anno dopo nel 1916 un anno
dopo la pubblicazione della relatività
generale
beh non fu veramente preso in seria
considerazione inizialmente perché le
increspature prodotte nella struttura
dello spazio tempo sono molto piccole
anche noi possiamo produrre onde
gravitazionali se ci muoviamo ma
einstein si rese conto che l'effetto che
noi produciamo è veramente trascurabile
non misurabile sicuramente dagli
strumenti che esistono in neanche da
quelli che potremmo sviluppare nel
futuro dobbiamo guardare quindi amasse
ancora più grandi molto concentrate
molto dense con grandissimi
accelerazioni quindi a oggetti celesti
lui stesso a un certo punto penso che
queste onde di gravità fossero solo un
risultato matematico della sua teoria ma
che non corrispondessero a nessuna
realtà fisica e sicuramente fatto di non
poterle produrre in laboratorio e
misurarle contribuì a creare questo
scetticismo per cui rimasero nell'oblio
il concetto di honda rimase nell'oblio
per una quarantina d'anni finché felix
pirani dimostrò che l'onda
gravitazionale trasporta energia che
questa energia può essere assorbita
quindi può essere misurata l'idea fu
raccolta da joseph weber che fu il primo
a cominciare una vera attività
sperimentale e siccome l'onda
gravitazionale produce un effetto che è
di deformazione dello spazio tempo e di
tutti gli oggetti che sono in esso
contenuti liszt era lì comprime allora
il relatore che weber aveva immaginato
era un cilindro che sotto l'effetto
dell'onda gravitazionale avrebbe dovuto
essere deformato come due masse tenute
insieme da una molla e una volta passata
l'onda il cilindro avrebbe dovuto
vibrare dissipando pian piano l'energia
catturata dall'onda gravitazionale erano
proprio queste vibrazioni che einstein
che weber voleva misurare di fatto alla
fine degli anni sessanta ci fu anche un
annuncio di una prima scoperta che però
non fu mai confermato da esperimenti
simili ma che stimola tantissimo
l'interesse verso questo campo di
ricerca l'eredità in italia fu raccolta
dai guardo maldi e da guido pizzella che
la promossero a livello non solo
nazionale ma internazionale contribuendo
a sviluppare strumenti tipo quelli di
weber ma ancora più sensibili e mentre i
rivelatori alla pepper venivano
costruiti ed entravano in misura si capì
però che questi segnali erano veramente
molto piccoli che bisognava sviluppare
dei dei rivelatori degli strumenti
ancora più sensibili l'idea fu
inizialmente proposta a dare i vice che
poi insieme con keep torna e con rond
river proposero alla costruzione di uno
strumento quello che poi
diventato laico da questa parte
dell'oceano ora in corso studi simili e
verso la fine degli anni ottanta nello
stesso periodo fu proposto alla
costruzione di virgo specialmente ad
opera di adalberto giazotto and deal
embry e l'idea era di usare la luce per
misurare il passaggio di un'onda
gravitazionale quindi la luce emessa da
un laser si doveva dividere in due fasci
che rimbalzavano su degli specchi
tornavano indietro e quando l'onda
gravitazionale arrivava cambiando le
lunghezze dei bracci deformandoli
avrebbe prodotto una variazione della
quantità di luce letta da un sensore
proprio questa alternanza di luce e di
buio rappresentava il possibile
passaggio di un'onda gravitazionale il
problema qual è che lo spostamento di
questi specchi in questo strumento che
noi chiamiamo interferometro è
piccolissimo gli specchi si spostano di
un millesimo delle dimensioni di un
nucleo atomico è una grandezza
inimmaginabile e per misurare questi
spostamenti è stato necessario costruire
degli strumenti estremamente sensibili
al momento esistono tre grandi
interferometri 2 lago negli stati uniti
e uno virgola vicino pisa sono strumenti
i grandi hanno bracci lunghi 34
chilometri perché l'effetto prodotto
dall'onda aumenta all'aumentare della
lunghezza e lavorano come se fossero un
unico osservatorio i dati vengono
analizzati insieme quelli che provengono
dai vari siti questa importante perchè
con un solo strumento non avremmo mai
potuto distinguere l'effetto dell'onda
gravitazionale da uno dei tanti disturbi
locali inevitabilmente sempre presenti
con due o più strumenti invece è
possibile distinguere qualcosa che
arriva dal cosmo da qualche disturbo
locale perché l'onda gravitazionale
quando arriva sulla terra
ma investe la attraversa come se la
terra fosse del tutto trasparente e
quindi lo stesso segnale arriverà prima
su uno strumento poi su un altro
poi su un altro noi quindi cerchiamo lo
stesso tipo di segnale in coincidenza su
più rivelatori è una grande
collaborazione sono più di mille persone
siamo più di mille persone tra fisici
ingegneri studenti tecnici che hanno
lavorato per moltissimi anni per mettere
a punto strumenti sempre più sensibili
questo è passato attraverso un grande
sviluppo tecnologico molte componenti
che attualmente sono utilizzate non
esistevano quando abbiamo cominciato a
costruire largo e virgo fatto sta le
cose sono andate avanti ea settembre
dello scorso anno
i due interferometri americani che erano
entrati in misura da pochissimo dopo un
lungo periodo di fermo di sosta sempre
per migliorarne la sensibilità
i due interferometri il 14 settembre del
2015 alle ore 11 e 50 ora italiana
hanno entrambi misurato uno stesso
segnale a un certo punto ci siamo
accorti che l'uscita che è normalmente
un segnale così un po confuso nel tempo
ha cominciato ad assumere una forma
particolare vedete un'onda che aumentava
nel tempo in ampiezza in frequenza i
picchi diventavano sempre più vicini tra
loro fino a raggiungere un massimo
seguito poi da una scilla zione che
lentamente si è spenta questo è un segno
e un segno e una firma del fatto che
questo tipo di segnale è arrivato da un
sistema di due buchi neri che hanno
orbitato per milioni di anni 1 intorno
all'altro si sono avvicinati sempre di
più e vedete in questo loro
avvicinamento hanno deformato moltissimo
la struttura dello spazio tempo
generando
quelle perturbazioni che abbiamo visto e
producendo un segnale quello che vedete
lì sotto è il segnale calcolato dalle
equazioni della relatività generale noi
abbiamo non solo misurato un segnale
così piccolo ma quello che abbiamo
misurato era quello che einstein aveva
predetto che succedesse quindi questa
honda che aumenta in ampiezza in
frequenza un certo punto nel momento in
cui i due oggetti si fondono raggiunge
il massimo si forma il buco nero finale
figlio dei due buchi neri progenitori
che oscilla ancora un po e poi si quieta
questo è stato il segnale che noi
abbiamo misurato come vi ho detto
qualcosa di piccolissimo qui sulla terra
ma lì dove è stato generato un miliardo
300 milioni di anni luce lontano da noi
lì se il nostro rivelatore fosse stato
là vicino a quei buchi neri avremmo
visto avremo misurato lo spazio stirarsi
e comprimersi cambiare la distanza di
centinaia di chilometri come se matera e
potenza si fondono cataclisma ecco ma
questi segnali quando viaggiano pian
piano si attenuano è per questo che dopo
aver percorso una distanza così grande e
sono arrivati così piccoli sulla terra
ma siamo riusciti a misurarvi questo è
stato il primo segnale misurato nel
periodo di presa dati che è durato
qualche mese ce ne sono stati altri
generati da buchi neri e che si sono
fusi e studiando come cambia la forma
dell'onda come cambia l'ampiezza e la
frequenza nel tempo noi siamo in grado
di misurare le masse di capire quanto
vale la massa dei due oggetti dei due
buchi neri progenitori e quanto vale la
massa del buco nero figlio è la prima
volta che si è misurata
così la massa di questi oggetti
direttamente si è visto il segnale che
avevano
prodotto e se ne sono visti due orbitare
uno intorno all'altro per noi questa è
veramente è stata una grande scoperta e
rappresenta l'inizio di un nuovo modo di
guardare l'universo che noi conosciamo e
abbiamo sempre visto a partire da
galileo quando mise per la prima volta
il suo occhio nel cannocchiale per giove
con i suoi satelliti l'abbiamo sempre
visto grazie alla luce con la radiazione
elettromagnetica che viene emessa dai
corpi celesti per la prima volta
l'abbiamo misurato in un modo diverso e
possiamo veramente dire che è stata
fondata una nuova astronomia perché
queste onde di gravità sono in grado di
rivelare delle caratteristiche delle
sorgenti che sono assolutamente
inaccessibile a qualunque altro tipo di
strumento chiaramente capirete
l'emozione quando abbiamo visto nei dati
dei nostri strumenti quel segnale ha
rappresentato questo il coronamento di
tanti anni di lavoro da parte di tante
persone lavoro con passione con
dedizione ci parla questa scoperta della
capacità di compiere delle imprese
ritenute inarrivabile fino a qualche
tempo prima ci parla anche della
capacità però di rimettersi in
discussione
quando ci si rende conto che le scelte
fatte non sono proprio le migliori
possibili per andare avanti per
migliorare sempre di più
e allora io voglio finire leggendo
insieme con voi un pensiero che riassume
molto bene questi sentimenti questo
stato d'animo è un pensiero scritto da
un filologo della scuola normale
superiore di pisa parla di questa
scoperta e dice allora perché è
importante ci saranno certo implicazioni
scientifiche cruciali ma non è per
questo che ci fa così impressione questa
scoperta ci sembra così importante
perché
fatta bene per arrivare a questo
risultato
centinaia di uomini e di donne hanno
lavorato al massimo della loro
creatività e della loro precisione
questa scoperta ci impressiona perché
abbiamo come genere umano spinto le
nostre conoscenze oltre il limite oltre
un limite è quasi impensabile
impensabile persino per lo stesso
einstein e questo è un atto di bellezza
una vetta della creatività umana
[Applauso]